今日はドクター始めたここ私の寝室なんですけどもつい先ほど
ここにあった別途用意しましたなくしましたというか自分であとちょっと方好きだと
言いますか
大的な睡眠をしたいというわけで今回なんとですね
なんとそれでもコーラマップ
まあ何がすごいかっていうのを説明する前に手で俺このままだってますよ頭が無いので
さぁ
即作っていきます
[音楽]
大口径ん
あのあぁそうきた受けたオフケアを受け
めっちゃかんだねもう工具なしでここまできた
それを一人で
[音楽]
アーサーした起きたわけ合えできました
ジャパめっちゃ簡単でした
ベッドフレーム作ってもと何回かあるんですけど本当に大変で
結構しんどい作業なんですけどもこれ子は玉鳥さんのげってくればなるけどじゃバイ
本当に簡単でしたもうパワースパッスパッやっぱり
サーカー
頭部からです次が本来のコアラマットです早速おいていきましょう
めっちゃコアなそっかパッケージがめっちゃかわいいですよねコアな
さあ春気遣いのコメントまで書いてあります早速上げていきましょう
1睡眠はマットレスが決まりますからね人類は駅てる時間の3分の1は睡眠で過ごすと
言われていますつまり人間生きるようなベッドの柱情勢とても大きい本なので
まで目 dec 部の na ことが落ちにせよ素敵に置くポイントなのです
ようこそ配らマットレスませんオープンくらいあっ
桜まあすごいもうねコーラが頑張って作ってるんだよそしてもうすぐですコーラ
マットレスの寝心地を楽しむには
ぎゃんばれちゃい腕なんか広げるだけって書いてあったからっ
足クサれてねえええええ入っ
できましたこれがコアラマット嬉しいでございますすごい
あんな小さかったのにもうちょっと厚みが出てきた導入正午の鮮明されたベッド
コアラバットレスなんですけどもう何がすごいかといいますとこちら
振動を吸収する0 this ターバンせ技術というものを使用されております
例えば鉄例えば
例えばなんですけど禿げ方に後結婚してお嫁さんと一緒に寝る間になって
こういうめちゃ一緒に寝るじゃないですかそういう時僕が願い手を打つと俺の嫁が
願い便の進度で多くちゃうかもするんですねそれがきっかけでないか夫婦の関係が悪く
なるとかいいじゃないですか癒さ
それがコアラまった様子だったら0 d star バンス技術によってなくなるん
ですね
夫婦で寝てても友達と音でもカップルで出てても朝まで
大的に出ることができるらしいんです1回でてみますお
大
あああうーんめちゃめちゃ撮影中に眠くなるぐらいすごい柔らかいです
[音楽]
まずでる子は黙ったりすごいなこの0 d star 板技術だけではないこちら
ここ更紗に分かれておりまして一番上のこここが低反発と高反発を融合した
通気性のある独自サーバにクラウドセルを使用し低反発すぎても疲れるし高反発すぎて
も寝心地はで競っているようなポイントを取っておりますここで中間層2月は衝撃を
吸収するために9社の約4
ています1ましたのか創部ここは願い打つやってしっかりと高反発でサポートしてる
みたいでございます
俺商品の紹介うまいな朝方残して練ってると重さが好かかるんですよねガットを o
さんがかかる場所にってかなさを変えるゾーニング警報というのを使っておりまして寝
てるだけで体をバランスよく支える作りとなっておりメスって口レベ
選べないってでも本当に壊れマットレスねすごいよとか分からないと思うのでいく時代
に0時スターまず技術試してみようと思います
さあ隣に隣にワイングラスを置いといても
新聞倒れないということだと思う強いも栄光大丈夫だよね
もうちょっとゼロでしたバギー土地にしているかそれで俺が乗っても指が伝わらないと
いうことでしょ
おおおお
すごいすごいすごい港も大丈夫ですこれないんね大丈夫よね
願いに打っても大丈夫起き上がっても大丈夫
ちょっと絶対入れる茶室のベッドだと
もうすごい
4恋でも大丈夫そうねぇ
[音楽]
はあああああ
これジャンプして年を経ると行くぞ
終わった怖いよ大丈夫だ
うわぁ
本当にこっちと町本当に強いんですよね ua したくないけどこれまったりの減ると
いうより
マット椅子自体は推計性経験を救助してくれますすごい
ほいっ
漆喰けどうーんいやあああっ
というわけでこんだけやっても倒れないということはちょっとこれドッキリでいけない
かと思いまして普通こういう
マットレスに飲み物を置いておくこと自体相当強いと思うんですよ
ベッドの上に絶対こぼしたらヤバそうないろんな色の液体が入ったワイングラスを
たくさん作っていきます
これはほん語などオレンジジュースです
ハースこんなけカラフルだったさすがにこぼすの怖いでしょ
だけで絶対にこうしたくないいろんな色の液体が入ったワイングラス準備しました
早速コアラマットですねおいていきます
これで
ターゲットがいる時に俺がここに飛び込みます
大丈夫だよね俺ちょっと本当にさんやなんだけどまずこぼした件で9
大丈夫ぞ
はーい
あっほい俺が叫びそうなんですけどもうこれ駒田待っとると住んでいるしかありません
早速ターゲットがいるところで私が当然ベッドに飛び込みますでは
[音楽]
me
se
ほんと強いはずじゃあやよいえっ
うえっ
ぶーぶーっ
凄い凄いしゃースタジャンてると願いとか起き上がるの全九州する待ったですん
た
めっちゃいい待ってるじゃないですかかいますが買えます
おっとっとつファンタ肩入れしてるん
でもんっ
で付せん
ちょっと勇者するよ
そうそういうベットはなったぁー
えすごくないですねこれどうですかコーラバッグです
声ます
あっはんちゃんだったんだパターン
大はははっはー
飯間てすせああっ
凄い凄いするんですよ
コア灰音が言ったり跳ねたりしても振動を吸収するマットレス子はなかった子です
買えますか
[音楽]
あああああ
飯山てありがとうバンカーんがぁ
すご普通ほんまめっちゃする2
それは絵の具これでええこれで落ちない
えっすぐどうぞ
全然湯出なかった呉山を越える待ってるかいますか
実を迷ってたんですよね追証ございます
はあああああ
ドッキリ大成功ですねー
怖いめぐも大丈夫って分かっててもその分かります
めっちゃ怖かったけどまずで倒れなかったりあの異形で飛び込んでも倒れない
コーラーとです最強でございますちょっとネットでコーラマットレス調べたんですけど
も yammer 結構注目度高くて今話題のマットレスらしいしても俺ももう実感し
ました
マジでこれ睡眠の質上がると思いますで反発
-もなく高反発いくものにすごい舌用の感じでまずで寝やすいです皆さん
チーズ a の3分の1は睡眠と言われています人生を変えたい皆様是非と睡眠の質
から帰ってください
夫だけで子はなマットレスの詳しい情報は動画概要欄であります8
僕最近の一番緊張した時だった是非ご覧全く使ってみてください
じゃあ
[音楽]
blr